the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is brought to you by
hellotushy.com but days are back the
church of what's happening now is
honored to introduce you to
hellotoshi.com hellotushy.com makes
portable devices that spray your butt
completely clean with water that's right
uncle mike completely clean with water i
don't know what i did before i had it go
to hellotushy.com church right now to
get 10 off of your order
that's hysterical
here you go
another fun-filled [__] afternoon
uncle joey uncle mike
the flying jew my main man
lee syed
a lot of love baby
the church of what's happened now
thursday
the 19th
of january
get your [__] together or this is gonna
happen to you right there you're gonna
take your car ask your [__]
girlfriend your [__] credit cards
there you go
[__] tremendous nothing but [__]
balls heart and soul listen to that
[__]
what's happening you bad savages
lee syed uncle mike here you don't need
to know nothing about mike mike's my
uncle he's my best man at my wedding
i've been hanging out with mike since
1990 since i got out of the halfway
house
maybe a year before i got into stand-up
comedy
so we're gonna go over a few [__]
crazy stories tonight you said it was
like
you were on my age when you met mike
roughly
i'm not sure so 90 i was uh 27 years old
well yeah yeah younger than me he was
smaller
oh a lot smaller
a lot smaller i was just i just got out
of the joint when i met you you were
fighting like oh i was fighting weight i
was hitting the bag i was swimming i was
lifting [__] weights i was running
and bull you know boulder
uh at that time in 1990 was a very
you know when you looked at they had a
newspaper boulder and then they had a
section about activities
everything was health relatedly
in those days like
there were bars in boulder that had a
thing called friday afternoon club
uh
at a bar that was one of the hottest
discuss those spots in the country like
it made playboy magazine
you couldn't even [__] drive on
arapahoe boulevard on friday from all
the people that would come from all over
the state wyoming
justin hook up it was fac friday
afternoon club
and uh
beside that there were the pearl street
bars pearls where
our friends the jewish guy's wife worked
bartended wasn't there
fathers potters and there were those
string of bars but that's it that was
one strip club the bus stop
yeah that sounds terrible
they were all cu codes they were all
[__] girls from the university and
the funny thing was that the guy died
and he left it to a church
and the church inherited the [__]
strip club
and they were thinking of selling it see
we were doing those bong hits to
stop banging on the [__] table please
for the love of christ hey so uh
there was the bus stop so there wasn't
much
much to [__] do in both in those days
besides work out
you know everything was health related
moonlight
walk in the mountains there's [__]
snakes and mountain lions up there in
the top where you want to go for a
[__] moose walk at night you know
everything was like very
health oriented in boulder it was very
rough to be fat
when you went to the ymca in bolderly it
was three fat people out of a hundred in
it
because the city was so
health
oriented so why was it tough to be fat
you felt bad or i kind of like what what
was tough about it it's the culture it
was the culture you know it's like
you know like look we lit we live in
this
incredibly we we live in this incredibly
beautiful spot you know how we all ended
up there is who the [__] knows
i don't know how i ended up there that's
another story and then bumping into him
on the street coming down from the
halfway house
and and that's just
you know i got that moment like frozen
in my head you know there was a mexican
place
that day
their menu was a healthy
there was a few blocks in boulder
uh in those days that was the original
restaurant was called the harvest lee oh
yeah you've spoken to the vegetarian
place harvest was yeah if i have to sit
here with you and go one of my favorite
restaurants of all time it was the
harvest
what made me go in there lee i don't
know the iced tea was the best iced tea
it had caffeine in it to the
to the gills it was stronger than greasy
tony's [__] mountain dew
when they tried to put a new iced tea
the [__] town signed the petition of
bold this is how [__] crazy boulder
was in those days they got a petition
together against the restaurant to bring
back the [__] teeth the original tea
oh they were gonna boycott the [__]
restaurant
how do you think you always end up in
these crazy cities like like north
bergen bolt like
because you changed your mind right like
you weren't going to boulder
the truth of the matter was i ended up
in boulder because i owed sixty thousand
dollars
you know i [__] uh
i was a suspect and you know and
burglaries from two years before
i was under investigation some guy had
turned and they called him his wife
stealing
from the city of aspen
so his return was that he'd bring in
drug dealers oh no so he went
to different people and he whenever he
comes to my house he'd go let's go talk
outside
that's how i knew he had cops close by
with the paramount bug like oh no
[__] and then one night what i
did was i went to my friend carl's house
and i left my car there and i took his
car and i took a ride around the
mountain and i came down my mountain
instead of go up it
and i went behind this thing and there
were the [__] cars and there was the
telescope i saw it right there
and i just [__] went down
it was right around thanksgiving of 86
maybe
the giants were in the super bowl maybe
okay
yeah yeah and
i [__] was supposed to i ordered a
turkey this company was gonna kill a
turkey
and it was supposed to pick it up on
wednesday right
and that [__] tuesday night it starts
snowing and i'm feeding
[__] savage unfinding and these days
my paranoia had gotten so bad my guest
my paranoia had gotten so bad in these
days
that i couldn't even get high in my own
house
so i'd have to get a package and go to
lee's and get away 200 and say
take paul into the movies and don't come
back because you thought like they were
watching your house oh yeah so i would
only get high at people's houses i would
go over and pay them to leave their
house but didn't you think they were
following you to that person's house no
no no i would park the car and walk
through bushes and [__] camouflage
and rifles by that point my paranoia was
so out of control it was it was really
uh it was it was
it was i was ready to check into a
hospital but i i wasn't i was too proud
to admit it that cocaine had taken its
[__] toll it was like
seven hard monthly of six nights a week
eight ball a night no sleep
you know uh taking care of myself food
and working out but no sleep just living
on [__] two hours a night
and here it is november and i told the
girlfriend
i'm going for a ride keep rubbing your
hands keep rubbing your hands in front
of the microphone yeah is that what
happens you're gonna light a fly and i
told the girlfriend at the time who
ended up being my wife i was gonna take
a ride
i went i copped a [__] 3 21 grams
and i paid cato 100 bucks and a little
coke to get the [__] out of his
apartment
and i stayed there from tuesday night to
thanksgiving around five i still
remember watching like one of the
football games and going
when is this coke gonna end
and kayla's knocking on the dog come on
i gotta [__] cook like my aunt's
coming over
would he go to your house what did he do
i walked into my house and she was
halfway
she was halfway back she goes i don't
know what to do people been calling here
people looking for your money
some guy knocked on the door the guy
from the supermarket called the turkeys
down there waiting for you you ordered a
turkey you were supposed to like i i was
gonna do the scarface type dinner like i
was out of my mind
like dinner for eight we were gonna
start partying wednesday and then eat
turkey nobody was gonna [__] make
turkey
and i had borrowed my i had contact in
those days i used to go to people and go
uh mike you got three thousand yeah i'll
give you back forty four hundred in two
days
give me three thousand and i had gone to
this guy that was in police academy his
mother owned a pizza place
in snowmass village his sister and her
husband on the pizza place and he was a
pizza dude
and he was starting to be a cop but he
would he would always come to me and say
i wanna i wanna know the other side of
the world
so finally after like
three years where it is that's like him
begging me for a year i got him for
three g's
and i got somebody else for like four
g's
and i and one of my drug deals
i'd gotten a pound of pot that mike if
you looked at it you were like this weed
looks [__] tremendous it smelled
tremendous you could smoke 80 joints of
it nothing would happen not even bad
breath
nothing this weed was [__] horrendous
i took that seven grand
i took that seven grand i had to pay off
two or three people like two or three
thousand
i kept like four grand
and that friday right after thanksgiving
everybody kept calling me calling me i
said listen i'm taking a trip on tuesday
i'm coming back with 22 ounces by this
time i knew everybody was watching me
so i told everybody on the phone
you follow me so even if the people were
watching me they thought i was taking a
trip on tuesday
if we're gonna bust him let's wait till
tuesday he's gonna take a plane and
we'll get him on the way back with the
cocaine was anyone ever listening or
were you just doing it yes no the the
phones were tapped if we were on in
those days they had to put a tag on your
phone on your phone on your phone box
where your phone box was there's no cell
phones there was no cell phones yeah
yeah so they had to put the defense how
to put a certain tag or the state of
local cops had to put a certain tag on
your thing
so you'd go to whoever had that box you
would break into it yourself and that
would be the [__] thing then they
sold these boxes
you could buy these boxes in those days
and connect them to your phone
and have people call you and if the the
thing turned red the phone was tapped
that [__] thing was always red
don't worry about where you get this
[__] all right just just just listen and
learn
so i told everybody on that phone that i
was going back to the east coast
to pick up a kilo of this [__] that
noriega had processed themselves i had
them i had these people salivating why
because i wanted them to butt think i
was gonna come back on tuesday and that
was gonna bust me that was gonna give me
four or five days to get the [__] out of
town knucklehead
they're waiting for me till tuesday
they're gonna stop watching me i'm gonna
get in my car and head to [__]
boulder wherever the [__] we're gonna go
oh my god so you're not coming back who
the [__] do you think you're doing why
would you put that on the phone so on a
late friday night when everybody was
[__] napping nunu and thinking we'll
just get him on tuesday
i packed what i had in the car i got the
[__] dog i got that half pound of
weed and i went to this drug deal i owe
thirty thousand to
and i said listen i know you've heard
this before
i know you've heard this before
but we gotta make this deal i got this
guy he wants an ounce of coke
i got like a thousand bucks and a pound
of wheat i will be back here in one hour
with the balance and if you want to keep
the pound you can keep it for 500.
or i cut her a deal her eyes sputtered
this bag of weed for 500 it's tremendous
you thought she had a deal i said don't
smoke entirely
don't smoke until i leave i got in that
[__] it's a dirty business this coke was
[__] tremendous this girl got in fact
she lives here now in los angeles and
she's a manager she's somebody's
assistant uh randy jackson somebody
big's assistant
i owed her like dirty large i [__]
took that [__] bouncer blow i got in
that car
i did two bumps
and i got on the road to boulder because
the girl i was with was from bold
and this is where new york was or this
is snowmass village right okay
it took us two days to get back to
snowmass village the four-hour [__]
drive yeah snowmaster boulder it's four
hours it took us two days you know
wildly
we were scenery we were so paranoid we
would check into hotels
do a line of coke and then check out and
get out
we checked into four hotels one night
that's how [__] paranoid you are
the sex on coke must just be amazing
because every other coke story sounds
terrible at that point the sex was good
but it didn't matter the cops were
looking for me i had no time to [__]
love ew all right it's
[__] business there's a time for
lovey-dovey and there's a type of
[__] business all right
so we just drove back to boulder
and i got the money i had left over and
i got a little apartment up in north
boulder with another guy that didn't do
coke but he did more coke than the both
of us and his creepy girlfriend they
would lock themselves in the bedroom
oh it's a [__] horror show it was a
[__] hour show
that i couldn't find the job so i got a
job at the car wash as a towel guy
and i was drying off [__] cars oh no
the puddle car wash
then i got promoted to [__] like the
second tile guy like the guy who brings
the towels out to other [__] idiots
and [__]
52 hours a week for seven bucks a
[__] hour
that's it that's what you would do
then i'm gonna join no no no then from
there i went over to bill crouch's body
shop
first okay bill crouch had a body shop
out down 57th of the rapper hole i
forget the guy's name good dude and the
dude that was running the place was from
new york i detailed no first i started
as a shagger
85 hours for [__]
guys i forget what it was it was
i started working for them it was 60
hours a week and i got 800 a month flat
and so and what does shagger do you want
to tell me which i got this i clean
bathrooms
i give people rides when they drop their
cars off i give them a ride so i had to
be there at six
to start giving people where i'd steal
the change out of the car the roaches
the guitar clips anything i could steal
it was gone i don't know what happened
to it the vacuum cleaner took
you know me the [__] vacuum i don't
know nothing
literally the hardest two or three
months of my life because i couldn't
quit i wouldn't let myself quit
the money was garbage
but i had to prove it to myself that i
still had it that doesn't even sound
like it was minimum wage it was horrific
it's uh it was horrific it sucks i made
the best of it because i hustled there
the people liked me people would say you
know what wash my car take a 20 off the
top i got weed there i bought coke there
i had friends there had you already been
a car salesman at that point no i didn't
i didn't do nothing at that point so
yeah that's why and granted yours sounds
like a little harder than being a pa but
it or maybe kind of the same maybe but i
think those kind of jobs are important i
think like even for a couple months
that's the job with
i had a manager that was a [__] dick
his name was dirk jordan or dirk johnson
or something like that i forget this
[__] jerk off right he was one of
these dudes that was a [__] geek
but they made him a manager and he would
pull rank on you and [__] like that
richard he thought he was real [__]
cute so he would pull rank on you
so one day i'm sweeping like i had i'd
lea i did everything shitty i emptied
the oil
i had to take the cars after a collision
and vacuum them and then drive them
around i'd get glass stuck in my [__]
neck and [__] jesus and then they
[__] fixed the car and then after
they painted i'd have to wash it
and put a special thing on and then dry
it really good then give it back to them
and then i had to help this dude who
installed stereos lee i did everything
there for 800 a [__] month yeah then
they finally promoted me to a detail
i was a junior detailer which meant i
was on commission but i was guaranteed
100 bucks a day and i was making 150 200
a day because you know me dog
they had these cars that came off the
boat with cosmoline on them
all right when you bought when you
bought a honda in those days uh uh
toyota toyota what did they what did
they have they had crouch honda nissan
crowd subaru
crouch uh mitsubishi
all those cars came with cosmoline on
them
and then i got a coating it's a coating
for the ship
so the salt and that type of stuff
doesn't get into the car oh gotcha
so you got to wash that cosmoline off
with a special chemical some nasty [__]
you gotta wash it off first and then i'd
have to take the wrapping off and i have
to put the floor mats down
i'd have to push a button to connect the
stereo
i have to do like four or five things on
the checklist those that car took two
hours they gave you like 30 bucks
if it was a used car you got like 35
bucks which is four hours
but if you were involved in a lottery
you know what i'm saying
so you took them as they had them but i
became friends with the people at the
honda place who was a girl named lori
roller
lori ended up marrying our drug dealer
vince
all right that's where they met at the
honda dealer she was the hot blonde
behind the thing
me vince we all worked together did you
know that that's why i met vince
at boulder auto body that's why i met
these [__] in 87.
he was the head detailer
he knew everything he was the baddest
[__] he's the hardest one he was
the baddest [__] there so dirk
used to pull rank on us and one day i'm
cleaning out the gutter the the circle
thing where all the drain water goes in
from washing the cars and there's a
[__] rat
that's dead
so i look over to the side and there's
dirk jordan's jacket was hanging on the
hook wow so i took the [__] rat i
dried it with paper towel
and first of all i look like you say he
pulled rank he's your manager he said
he's my manager but he was one of those
dudes that was a manager but he's lucky
to be breathing he's a [__] [__]
he's lucky to be breathing one of those
managers that you look at and go really
i will [__] out matthew the debt you
understand me i will out matthew the
death
choose the algebra [__] like they just
got manager because they've been there
yeah he was a [__] [__] you know and
then he had this little certain rank to
him so
i took that rat and put it in his pocket
right
i [__]
i went home i forgot all about it and
the next day he comes in his car is all
banked up and [__] he reached his pocket
for cigarettes
and there was the [__] rat
and he almost had a pole hit like a
[__] farmer's thing
so boom one gag over the [__] peter
pinto
all right
i'm sure that's his real man
stop coughing in the [__] microphone
you're worse than i am god damn it
i don't know now sniff a little too
right in the [__] microphone
when you gotta do anything move away so
these people don't live the experience
is that how this works yeah you gotta
move away there you go there you go
don't drink water because then they get
mad at me and they get mad at me for
everything every day i got a [__] new
note stop drinking water i'm gonna sit
for three hours and talk and dehydrate
so it was a dude peter pinto
who you knew was a [__] thief married
to marry muslims from day one and
there's this young kid that worked for
me no no i'm lying to you guys i'm lying
to you guys okay
so
that in those days it was the honda
store
the subaru store and the mitsubishi
store the honda store was very white
everybody wore a nice suit
subaru
you could tell these guys might have had
a felony
or they might rob somebody or they were
on the run for killing their wife or
something okay i can live with that
but the mitsubishi store was the [__]
raiders
they were all it was the two indians
little means
they had three salesmen that were over
six foot four
yeah two big [__] indians that were
over two ninety
six foot six and then was they fit into
mitsubishi's those little jeeps when
they were tipping over they had them
they were selling them my car they were
selling them that label over there what
they call that sticker
those guys were making [__] 15 000 a
month in 1987 selling mitsubishi dog in
those days that place became a tire
store
that place like years later became a
tire store that little store
generated millions and those years of
mitsubishi those little [__] jeeps no
no no no no the ones that were tipping
over nah that's suzuki suzuki that was
uh they were selling suzukis and we were
doing
suzukis that's the [__] jeep they
were selling oh wow and they had like
four salesmen what's his name lee
iacocca he did that they were selling
they had four sales please at the subaru
store there was
seven salesmen
and in those days in 1987 they were
selling 135
cars out of there wheeler was the
gentleman the sales manager
peter pinto was the [__] uh
the new car manager
and there was no floor manager and i
would go in there every day and break
their balls hey what's up the suzuki
guys you couldn't say a word because
you'd get stabbed at that dealership
what does suzuki sell besides those
things that's it that's it they were
selling 80 cars a month over there and
the [__] subaru had seven salesmen
they were doing like 135 in the honda
store
that store was rocking in those days
there was a new car store that's before
john elway took over the other [__]
store in westminster and [__] them all
up in the ass because we didn't want to
buy a car from john our way everybody
okay so
okay so i'm dropping off cars to all
three dealerships and i become friends
of peter pinto and one day he goes why
are you what are you wasting your time
over here for
he invites me over because you should be
selling cars i said okay
i'll come over one day i'll take the day
off he goes no no you're gonna come over
for good
i took the day off from the body shop
just to see if i would like it on the
first day i sell three cars
i made a thousand bucks dog i had to
work four weeks to make 800.
my first day of selling cars i made
a thousand bucks and he gave me a
hundred dollar spiff you know cash in
hand that means i get a half gram of
coke i could fill up my car and i can
still have 10 bucks for a [__] egg
sandwich and a soda for breakfast you
understand me that's how you did the
math in those days it all started with
dollar bill okay a hundred dollar bill
got you where you gotta go
if you didn't need gas you just hit the
20 and used it for being oh my god
how did you sell three cars in the first
day dude i have no [__]
just off of uh
i leave i go to the chrysler store
i go back to the subaru store i get
arrested at the subaru store all right i
do time
mike uncle mike moves to boulder while
i'm doing [__] time
i get out they put me in the halfway
house but i met mike on the second tour
of the halfway house
because i was out already for a while
then they put me back in because i i had
the drug testing [__] so they put me
back in and now i had to be on i
couldn't i was they threatened me they
said listen any violation you're going
to go right back to uh prison
so in those days i didn't even drive see
before that i would drive i would hide
my car by the nissan dealer
and i would walk two blocks to the
halfway house that's how you scan them
you parked the car like three blocks
away deep in the bushes
off an off street with nobody expecting
it
and then you [__] go over there and
get in your car mike kessler's going
deep on the red stars of death why do
you hate following rules like because i
didn't want to walk around i'm going to
[__] pedestrians take a bus and [__]
like that i got a car why am i gonna
[__] walk around i got a car they
didn't let you but the second time they
put me in i walked everywhere i was like
[__] jesus i walked up and down that
[__] 28th street there was the nissan
dealership then across the street if you
walked up a little bit there was a
lickham store yeah and there was a place
where i paid for a mailbox
oh and i was and then if you kept
walking up more then you hit the car
wash and if you kept walking up more you
hit ladizio in the buildings where i
lived that back there
so the second time around i was going to
college
and that's when i met
robert who was an english british jew
and he used to tutor me
in something
he used to either tweeted me in
economics or something and he sold cars
with my cat me and uncle mike hit it off
and then he took me to his house that
night
by chautauqua and your daughter was
young
and that's when we first became friends
that was way before comedy mike was even
on the horizon
i had just had a child
yeah we were like just a couple of model
parents yeah no nobody was a model
parent in those days not you i was like
the reason why i was lucky but we became
friends because of a guy named rob dando
right who i had worked with was a
straight guy right who was a straight
guy whatever but lee at that time
he was the guy i told you i used to
steal his lucky patent
i'm sorry lucky pen and you were every
day you'd hide it i'd hide it and one
day i gave him back the whole roll of
[__] pens so he left chrysler and
went to
they opened up a new toyota store all
the way on the other side of denver some
football player in fact it was john
elway and you didn't have to wear
certain
so mike and this guy rob dandel decide
to go all the way down there to sell
cars oh jesus you forget about all this
[__] i'm dropping you that's why you're
sitting there all half [__] because
i'm hearing i'm giving you all this and
you're sitting there going jesus just
got a memory like a [__] heart i
don't forget none of that [__]
unbelievable
wow
strange times man
that's how you knew rob then though and
that's how you connected with me now we
were all okay we all knew we did a
package from time to time
if you got a package that was a little
oversized you call me
if i got a package that was a little
oversized i'd call you
then i got divorced i went back to new
york
i came back
and that's when we connected heavy again
but we i wanted to tell people the
struggle you know when i sit here at
night and i talk about comedy and what
it this was the beginning of my comedy
career guys
i've moved back to colorado and i'm dead
serious about comedy like this is it i'm
not [__] around anymore
and there's a contest
at that time the denver comedy works
wasn't giving me any love nobody was
giving me love there was one club that
was giving me love on the sunday night
was called club mix
and it was a black club and when i'm
talking about a black club they were so
black there wasn't even white chicks
allowed in there like this place was
black jack and the chicks were black and
black but on sunday nights they did
comedy and cedric would come in
uh
any black comic you see that's big today
came in i'm not like like i never met
steve harvey but i'm that's why i met
cedric do you mean bernie mac
bernie mac would go there
uh
deal here the hugely would go there it
was one of those
it was one of those nights
that it was a black promoter would bring
in but before they brought up the stars
and they weren't stars in those days to
be honest they brought me and some other
local black comics
from [__] denver how are you a black
comet listen to me dawg
there was only two white dudes who were
allowed to perform there and it was me
and this cat named kevin fitzgerald that
was the veterinarian of mount animal
planet for many years he was a vietnam
vet that was also
a [__] killer that was also the stone
security for all those years and two
tours this guy was a bad [__]
they only liked me and him all the other
white acts that would go there on a
sunday they'd boom it was like it was
like 25 bucks in the drink ticket they
paid you
like i used to be like in heaven because
they'd pay me twenty dollar bill to do
[__] comedy
so i had to make a tape
i had to make a tape i didn't know
nothing about nothing i don't know about
no tape
so i went to mike and i go mike i gotta
[__] make a table because my daughter
works with cameras and [__]
why don't you uh
let her tape you sauna on a sunday night
we drove to east colfax
which in those days was hookers
and busted hotels and crack hoes and
[__] like this and lee i can't i can't
he's right there next to me
and we parked in there and his [__]
young daughter went in there set up a
camera amongst all these black people
she's she had to watch the camera with a
gun and a bazooka title like a terrorist
if you touched her the camera would go
off
i mean she take the [__] set lee it
was the worst set
you could ever imagine i was dancing in
the beginning i mean it was god garbage
but who gave a [__]
that's what this whole thing is about
like this is and he was with me he drove
me
yeah she has just she had solid gold
balls yeah this is 93 but then i'm
working for a sports betting joint and
mike comes to me when he goes my
daughter's doing a movie
and she wants you to play the bad guy
and she goes in fact she wrote it kind
of about you kidnapping a dude and put
them in the trunk of a car
and this whole thing right and this is
this guy's this is [__]
at this time i'm going to mike's house a
lot he's got a dog he's got two young
daughters
we're having a great time all the time
me and mike we're doing bumps we're
smoking dope we're going on missions in
boulder
listen you know me and mike are like me
and lou's when we were kids there could
be a [__] a foot of snow
and if we got an itch
it's gonna get scratched that's just the
way life is
at that time
you know he was my [__] ying and i
was his yang nobody understood him like
i did i still remember one day he called
me up crying telling me like it was the
devil i'm never gonna do cocaine again
i'm giggling on the other side going
mike you're talking to me no you don't
have to sing this completely serious at
the time yeah good right yeah right
[__] nuts so now we were [__] nuts
that's it
i'm divorced that was close to the end
i'm bringing my daughter over to mike's
house
my baby daughter at the time jacqueline
the older one she would play with the
dog remember the dog loved her and your
mother and your wife and the whole
[__] thing yeah
this is how deep we go back guys
but then we do this movie i agree to do
this movie up in this [__] town and
this is a good thing this is a good
thing and i agree to do this movie we do
this movie
i get that 12 o'clock and for [__]
lunch
i didn't know nothing about movies those
days you tell me 12 o'clock i'm ready to
go 12 o'clock i gotta get out of here i
didn't know nothing that you waited
around all day
do you know what time i shot guys
at four
in the [__] morning they woke me up
to shoot my scene so i got there at 12
o'clock sunday for lunch
and it was an all
day thing but something happened on the
way to the [__] park
that mike's gonna remember so
mike's wife has his friends oh geez here
it is this little cute little hip
i'm done and i'm [__] downtown
i am done
go ahead it's ugly it's
but now the funny thing is but here's
the thing is that
this movie
comes out and it's like good oh it's a
good movie yeah somebody still has it
somebody said they found the tape in
their house with my stand up on it it
wins uh
the prize it was like somebody named
goldberg or something it was
one down uh you know [__] blue ribbon
academy award [__] but
but on top of all this
uh
you know i'm tired
we've been there all [__] day
and i think i say something like that
yeah it was 24 hours
i got a [__] lay down
oh geez does he torture you with this
storyline no he don't know he forgot all
about it
i was thinking about what you know it's
the women that i love that that torture
they hate they hate me
you know i i become like the devil you
know so i go yes it's like they go what
you know what
why do you how could you hang out with
him i go on this toyota long bedroom
with a [__] with a shell on it right
i don't know nothing there's a pillow in
there i lay down right i'm minding my
own business
and also the truck opens up and this
chick's like hi what are you doing today
i'm gonna take a nap because this truck
belongs to me or whatever and she goes
i'm kind of tired it looks kind of warm
and cozy in there
i had like a blanket something i'm in
there laying down one minute we're
laying down the next one that was
swapped
what are you talking about it looks warm
and cozy in there that never happens to
anybody she starts laying next to me
oh
whatever the [__] happens
i don't know what happens let's don't
eat the monkey
then we just went for it [__] it we took
a chance columbus did well
while his daughter was shooting like a
student in film no yeah
this is this is 20 this is this really
small town outside of boulder right it's
like
it's like the lions oh my god it's like
lions colorado right this is terrible
and there's this like diner in town you
know and it's like
and it i mean the diner is real right
well we get the
people in the diner to let the kids
shoot a film there right okay this is cu
film school [__] so
uh my daughter gets this idea from this
story that uncle joey told her a long
time ago because that's what it was we
don't look at him as a criminal he just
had to be a very creative guy this is
how he got through life
so
anyway that's it but anyway so this
whole town for 24 hours
we shoot this [__] well anyway
listen he's i don't know what the [__]
he's talking about she sits next to me
we start swapping spit
i start fingering that we're getting hot
and nasty she's really cute she's just
way older than me
but she was dynamite man she had a great
[__] body
but
a little monkey was pissed oh my god and
i gave her a stab
i gave her stabbing christopher columbus
no condom no nothing that was tremendous
no condom is christopher columbus style
yeah and i gave her like three days
later they hate me at mike's house and
they said i gave her chlamydia
never been the same
it's never been the same
they hate
me you tell us who it was i don't know
her name this is the 20 [__] thing
what did you like disappearing to the
mist no this is this is well
if you gave somebody chlamydia wouldn't
you disappear into the mist
[__] uh what's her name no man this
had to be
this had to be january or february of
95. okay
and by this time i was doing comedy i
was trying to
do comedy i think mike would drive me
from time to time but at this time mike
also knew
mike knew when i had the rocky apartment
the one across the street from the ymca
downstairs do you remember that
apartment at all
[__] no look at you i don't know that
started death is killing it saying i am
you know it's
it's almost there i think it's all right
i was doing kind of i had a bench with
uh yes in the basement with the bench
and i had the [__] tub whatever the
the stand-up metal thing the wire
but i was always at your house you used
to make veal scallopini and [__]
spaghetti and all that cooking and then
you got a car and at the same time i got
thrown out of the comedy works
and you gave me the [__] car for 600
bucks
but
uh
like you were in boulder that whole time
when i was really angry about
yeah yeah
i was it was really bad for wally yeah
that's some tough stuff like he saw it
all he saw the whole
thing he saw me pack up my car
he saw me [__] head to the hills and
do comedy
and then we both reconnected so we both
left i left boulder in 95. okay
and i went
to seattle
i stayed up there for a while and then i
went on the road and hooked up with your
daughter in boston
she had a boyfriend and they lived in
boston
the young young daughter oh the stock
broker guys in laguna beach or something
now yeah
so then we [__] went
you called me one day and you said guess
what i'm coming to los angeles for
something
and we went to a christmas party
on sunset
me you my ex-manager jeff gatlin and his
wife and we went dancing at a bar and
you said you were coming back
and you actually came back like a year
later maybe i don't know
but you came back and again now at this
time i'm a regular at the comedy store
you know uh i wasn't doing movies yet
but
it was starting to click for me you know
you drove me to the apartment you were
there and met my wife i mean you were my
best man you know
nine years
later but
yeah it was about that time you know
also you were like uh
you were allowed to park your car at the
store yes
i was real impressed yeah yeah yeah we
never parked the car at the store
but also uh i mean there's like 50 guys
that can't park their car at the store
right no we're parking everything
in the back and drinking for free
but it's funny at that time i was also
in hell with the addiction thing you
know but i was still moving along that's
why i tell these people all the time
that
the coke problem i had was at night
at night late night when it was time to
[__] work
you know i was telling lee when you got
here that you drove me to the spider-man
2 audition on the sony lot on the
hottest [__] day of the year i had to
wear a black velour sweatshirt
and walk from the parking lot to the
spider-man's room
and he sat in the car and waited for me
he knew all these guys he knew gabriel
felipe
uh fly jeff garcia george perez
they used to call him the wolf
silent
bob silent bomb
fiction
like that
yeah they called them we were out every
[__] night doing something i i never
knew that that's where it came from
right until about
two years ago
he just got they go woof
three four nights a week till [__] 11
30 at night i was just hanging out i was
being like a teenager you know i was
like an idiot you know no
yeah it was great it was great talking
to you it was you were here with me now
now i had backup now i had family out
here you were
and then what did we do we did something
were you around for the longest yard yes
or no yeah
2004 when i was shooting down there now
yeah
yeah that's because here
spider-man 2 all that stuff yeah by the
way i saw that movie the other night
it was on and i was petting one of the
cats and i said you know what
i really don't want to move let me watch
this for a second jesus christ
it was the slowest 30 seconds of my life
i thought i was going to die of soft
pain
until doc takes that girl to the
restaurant by her throat that movie's
slowing and [__] molasses then it
picks up that's not bad that's one of
the movies that like and then oh you
you're funny and but like those that
that era of spider-man movies everyone
loved and i didn't get it the only one i
liked was the last one where they he
turned black and he was kind of dark but
then everyone else hated that one
but it was kind of weird
like i don't know i don't know i thought
he was a great peter parker there's one
scene where he's looking he's sitting
there and he's
going through changes like lisayet two
nights a week
and he [__] uh
he uh
here what do you call that i was looking
at him thinking transform and i looked
at him yeah and he really in my mind i
go yeah
if i had to think about what peter
parker looked like it would be yeah he
was oh yeah he really does he really
does so
i don't know
you know
mike uh starts to death
yeah i think i told you this is that
it's really weird because mike saw me at
my
worst
but then he walked me down the [__]
aisle to marry my wife so
it's just uh when you called me you said
you were coming to town i said what the
[__]
he got me a job in an accurate place one
time
i sold three cars and then one day the
guy got loud with me or something and i
don't know what happened i told him i
was gonna throw him to a plate glass
window or something i was [__] crazy
just out of prison [__] nuts
and i don't know what the guy said to
mike you pulled mike aside
[__] crazy they said
they said hurry
joey's got this manager up by the throat
right
i don't know why i thought it was funny
but i was laughing my ass off no i could
not think you'd hurt him already but by
now but uh
uh i remember coming over there
and kind of asking you like joey joey
this is like not a good idea
put him down would you you know it was
hysterical it was like i go visit
michael i came in i i came in and i got
that and i got the monster off him all i
had to do was ask
i'm serious dude i was there you didn't
hurt your guys i go visit mike one day
at his job and i was territorially
interchanged
and mike's talking about something lee
and at that time it's uh
the guy had been disrespectful by the
way
nice guy it was about what can i say ben
he's then he was a psychotic yeah this
is i think i look at him like i am oh my
god i was on the basement i was out of
my [__] mouth
i go to visit mike he's working in the
car store he grabs the manager he goes
to trinidad
that's not like that's not like a little
crazy
and i'm and i'm sitting i'm going like
i'm hanging out with this guy what the
[__] am i doing
but it was entertaining you know can the
rest of my life you know you know what
was have to have people say that a lot
of people listen and get to
it's at that point where
you figured out what you want to do with
your life
i'm still working hard but you know but
you have to have a job
to pay your bills
and you're only doing this [__] job
to pay your [__] bills
that was the point in my life i was at
like
all i want to do is be a [__]
comedian when is this gonna [__]
happen for me like that was what i was
going through at that time
and i'm trying to work and these people
are breaking my balls and all i want to
do
that's all i want to [__] dooley and
i couldn't figure out how to [__] do
it
that's one of the
most inner
worst that you could feel when you know
what you want to do
but you
can't
quite figure out exactly what needs to
be done
you know and i know i gotta [__] get
up in the morning
and sell [__] cars for a living am i
[__] [__]
you know what i'm not doing and that's
that was that those jobs like that i
would last a month adam until one day i
said i'm just gonna do comedy
and steal along the way
whatever's not nailed down whatever
however i can make money
i i'm gonna [__] do it you know
one of the times i rob one of the
dealerships
i don't think i have no idea what you're
talking about
ah i played the fifth
you know that and they blamed on
somebody else i don't know a [__]
thing
i'm serious
god is my witness there's no one on the
other side mike they're not like
i have no i
absolutely no knowledge he really
doesn't have any knowledge
you know we were talking like two days
later
and i said to him
i think it was like 80 dollars or
something no was it no no was there like
three bills
yeah yeah in those days my rent was 400.
yeah why do they have cash in a car
dealership
[Music]
who's coming in and buying
they make salesmen jump and you go hey
if you can like tell me too in like the
next hour i'll give you 200 bucks oh
yeah well then that deserves okay um
you know it's it's a job that you do
when you can't do anything else you know
you can't punch a clock you can't
and it's really about you know
can i communicate with people without
screwing them over and stuff you know
just it has nice carpets in it
you buy it i make a little money if i do
a lot of them we make some money i
started making good money but you know
we played it straight like [__]
hilariously
you know this is why i get happy
when i tap into my this part of my life
and tell me
it sucks but it makes me laugh because
in those nights
if i would do comedy how i would reward
myself i would go to ralph's the
supermarket
on 30th in arapahoe i pulled a name on
myself at about 11 30 quarter 12
and i'd buy a package of saltines
a little piece of adam cheese
and a little container freshly squeezed
orange juice
and i'd go to the accurate dealership
and i'd get out of my car and i look at
the cars and i eat the cheese and eat
the crackers at night
and think to myself one day i'll be able
to buy one of these [__] cars from
making comedy you know
this this is real [__]
then i had an acura
i was planning to [__] rob mike's
dealership and take one of the cars
and take it to my house and take the
rims off it and put it on my acura and
put the old rims on the other actually
take it back to the dealership you lee
this is this is
this was a complete different person
when i sit here in front of you i sit
here and we giggle about the stupidity
but this is where my head was at i had a
brand new acura me and mike went
to the [__] denver nugget game and i
hit black ice
and the rim hit the [__] thing and i
had to get a whole new rim i had alloy
wheels on this [__] acura each rim
was two thousand dollars weird i had two
dollars in my [__] account i don't
know anything about it yes you do don't
[__] lie
but then you also the driver before you
became the head driver here in l.a we
used to go out every night you were also
the driver in boulder for a few
comedy shows i forget
what where you drawing me
one time well you drove me to the black
club club mix but then you drove me
somewhere that was the name of club mix
yes but then you drove me somewhere else
i was talking to my kid about it yeah
i said how old are you 12 she says no no
i was uh she was in film school right i
think right who
when i met you guys
no and with this thing we were just
isn't that the thing that she uh
shot
what shot
you know she filmed
all right yes she was in film school at
that time okay yeah but i had met her
before that
because i had met you and he was friends
with you and i was friends with your
youngest daughter but i would go to a
restaurant named lodesia every day he
was another guy i met in the halfway
house i know the restaurant great for
him and his wife [__] great food now
they own the mediterranean
they're a peace owner of the
mediterranean and boulder but he's the
head [__] menu dude lee
forget about it here's a ravioli he puts
pancetta in it that little [__] like
real bacon italian bacon with the fat
more fat and a little fat all put on one
piece you know what that does to sauce
and he [__] puts chunkers pepper you
have no [__] idea my friend he is one
of the best his pizza i eat all the time
if i'm in boulder i haven't had his
beats in 20 [__] years what am i
talking about he's still there he's
still there he sold the restaurant
but he still does the [__] pizzas on
saturdays and sundays at the
farmer's market or whatever he'd be
worth it right if he shows up himself
with the oven and that's what he still
does hands on
he's got some great stories
i'm you know [__] bad bad bad
state of my mind it's
it's uh
maybe april
of 1995. i'm broke
my war with my ex-wife
i really want to do [__] comedy
and i got a call from mike that he's
coming over to pick me up because he's
working for a guy named jack smoot
and he needs to
pick up a car the guy was a wholesaler
when you wholesale cars at this time
mike was not a lot anymore he had become
a wholesaler would you go to uh
a [__]
what do you call those things on tuesday
and buy cars off the line options an
auction then you take them to
dealerships
so i'm in the car with mike it was a
freak show i was i had gotten fired from
my tuesday night hosting job at the
broker
why
because
things happened
no i got into an argument with the
manager there
the manager it just
it was my time to leave and you know i'm
saying
it was an argument that didn't nothing
really bad happened we just argued and
then they said you know what we're going
to get another host
and by that time i had already done my
time there my early i had gotten what i
could get from that room i had already
had 15 minutes of comedy i hadn't met
300 comics i had done
it was uh a year and a half i had done
every [__] tuesday night you know
but i'm with
mike it's about 11 o'clock at night
i got a pager at the time
oh god and i got a [__] page from uh
which is washington
and i [__] we run back to mike's
house with a calling card
and we [__] call
this number and it's a guy by the name
of david tribble
all right he goes joe diaz david tribble
he goes i hear good things about you
are you ready to go on the road
how was your mike the first time i got a
road job off it oh [__] that's awesome
and the guy offered me five weeks of
work
right off the bat
like right off the [__] back like
and i'm like absolutely i go when do
they start he's like tomorrow night
and mike had to do something we had to
get a car
we had to either rent it
we stole it from a lot
we borrowed it from a lot an owner
didn't something wasn't
we loaded that [__] up with
sandwiches
and anything else we could find and i
went on the road for five [__] weeks
i came back on the weekends and we
switched cars or something happened i
can't believe i did that yes that wasn't
me no somebody had gone with me
um
you know i remember what it was
somebody's girlfriend had gone on
vacation it was her car here we go good
story
something crazy like that
but all those times leave that when i
was struggling in the beginning economy
like that was
that was real man and then he moved to
l.a and like i said we were always out
on mondays mondays he would drive me up
to you i knew nothing about this one day
mondays he would drive me up to
universal city through ernie g's room
do you remember the g's room the room
yeah
we used to get cuban food up there there
used to be a versailles deadly oh
shampoo
cheater big cube the beer the big guy we
used to go up there i'm there on mondays
and we go to the comedy store and lurk
yeah tuesdays we go to casa latina
would fly and
uh jeff garcia i picked up my first 40
there
and then we go to
somebody else had a room on tuesdays and
i picked up 60 there felipe
and now we had a hundred 20 had to go
into the gas tank because mike had to go
somewhere the next morning
so we had 80 to work with now we got to
go to work now we got to go to the store
we got to work somebody for a small 40
or a 50. we got to show up with a story
you know what i'm saying i can't go home
with a half a gram it's too much work we
gotta go home with something
old school week old school we go out
with zero and come whatever we come home
with we split right down the middle
uncle mike i have a question
was joey always
said
making up songs because he always does
that i've never i don't know anyone else
who does it he just it's not like it's
not like he sings he makes up songs he
makes up everything he's [__] songly
what kind of question
i don't even know what you're talking
about what kind of songs do i mean like
like the songs when you call me to taunt
me i can't sing them now but no does he
ever wait did when you leave
my nose like those things no you guys
you wake up he'll wake you up and he'll
go uh hey you think you think about
licking my balls
right and you know
and and then like you'll take like in a
song on the radio but sing your own
lyrics to it
he tells you to go wash your [__] and
and you know come on down you know
you would say that back then oh yeah no
it's hysterical
uh
i don't know what can i tell you
this for a long time
entertaining
it's been a long [__] journey man and
that's what i was thinking about all day
today i wrote a little bit in the book i
wrote like two different chapters
and just thinking about all these little
things i made notes because it exercised
my mind
and maybe and made her
remember how hard 1994 and 1995 was
in more ways than one my health was
great
but my [__] i was getting beat up by
my ex-wife
you know if you've ever started anything
i was starting comedy one of the hardest
things to start and i was getting beat
up there but guess what at that time i
was out i was out every night at least i
had
see for the first three years of comedy
91 92 and 93
i just jerked around
i was just telling people i was doing
comedy i was getting on stage twice a
month
if i was lucky right i was like one
night i'd get fired up and go and i
would commit to it i'd drive
30 miles i'd
eat dinner out there and i'd go on stage
and bomb
and then i wouldn't go on stage for a
month but then i went to new york and i
realized and then when i went back to
colorado
i was out every
[__] night
i used to do comedy after a line dancing
thing
are you doing open mics open mics 20
paid gigs
it didn't [__] matter
it just didn't matter man i was paying
400 a month rent
the car i had could break down at any
[__] minute
at any minute that's why i had when i
went on the road and he hooked me up
with that car
that was the [__] car i took to
seattle and i uh
went and did my thing
so if it wasn't for mike
maybe i wouldn't be doing comedy right
now you know what i'm saying mike was a
good [__] dude then that's really
cool
that's uh at least i have no idea what
he's talking about at least mike
understood at that time
what i was trying to do mike had tried
micah tried to be a musician when he was
younger you know he had a family
he got to do different things that came
first
so i think that he do you remember when
i showed up at your house and spent the
night with that girl
because [__] we were on the road
together and i was spending the money
yeah and i spent the night in one room
and the other
at that night your wife was cool for
some reason she had forgiven me for a
week or so yeah and it came and then the
girl called and said my family
my wife was always cool she never she
never embarrassed anybody no that she
was cool
but she let you know but she let you
know she don't like you yeah yeah
no no she's a lady she's like uh
she's still cool she's my best friend i
never forgot i went to mike one day oh
michael
what are those people doing in the
corner over there
[Music]
there's some blow over there and he goes
no those those those black dudes sell
crack
and i'm like down so [__] cracking
about three months later
i'm driving home from the comedy store i
got no cocaine
and who's on the corner by man's chinese
theater
down the block on those corners right
there those four corners
well these three black dudes right
i look over at the dude he looks over at
me he knows what time it is oh my god he
comes over to the car he asked me what
i'm looking for not crack i make believe
i'm [__] yes i do lisa
i said what can i get for a 20. he calls
me a chunk of [__]
something i take it homely now in my
heart i know it's crack
but in my demented [__] uh
cocaine head
i wanted to be a regular coke
so why didn't you just go buy coke i go
because i couldn't get that everybody
was locked up or out of town
somebody had been shot i don't [__]
know lee i just couldn't get in and
nobody had it that night there's some
nights you [__] blank nobody's got it
there's nothing you could do
that's why you should not do the whole
packaging so i bought the [__] crack
i took it home and i tried to snort it
and then it didn't melt right and i just
went to bed i jerked off and went to bed
and the next day mike picked me up and i
told mike i bought a rock on the corner
he goes you [__] [__] that's not
coke
that's crack you got to get a crack pipe
and smoke it
and i just went and got a coke handed
for
about six weeks
eight weeks i smoked crack and [__] and
i used to tell my
like i smoked crackling i have no idea
what he's talking you know what i'm
[__] talking about what made believe
when you do 1200 milligrams like who you
what do you mean
you i
smoking crack
just randomly just for that i did it for
about eight weeks you smoke a crack the
way like people like sign up for social
media accounts just to see how it is
you're like oh this had to be
two thousand
you just try and i used to go to el paso
a lot in those days i used to go to el
paso every eight weeks try up here go
ahead live
headlines
for like three months right
how could you possibly do how could you
possibly do comedy
i don't know because this is what i do
nobody knew just you no but don't say
you don't have knowledge cox i'll stab
you in the heart with this pencil
i have no nobody [__] knew i i was
smoking crack
at that time my first choice was cocaine
so i would buy like a little bit of coke
and then go [__] it i might as well buy
a little piece of crack
i would have i would have soda at the
house which meant i had a crack pipe
because i would drink a soda and empty
it and then make little holes and i'd
smoke the crack i'd blow towards the
[__] can and i get high on the crack
so oh my god oh yeah lee i'm telling you
lee
we're lucky to be here sitting here
so holy [__] i go
to el paso
to do
comedy for a week
and when i get to el paso i don't know
how to get crack
so i had to go back to the snow and coke
so for six months goodness oh my god
that saved your life so fast
it did cost saved my life so for six
nights
i snorted coke
so for six nights i snorted coke and
guess what
ba boom i got off the crack
oh okay that's it exactly wonderful
thing
this is [__] craziness guys
this is really craziness that's madness
and i can't hear like he's making notes
of this [__] today
i can't imagine living my life like that
it would it seems like it would be
hell
yeah exactly i was already in hell
i was a [__] 30 something year old
trying to do comedy
in that way
who had nothing
very funny i shared a [__] apartment
i paid 350 a month and i could barely
come up with that
you know i wasn't i wasn't healthy i
didn't know what direction to go i was
getting on stage every night i was
[__] hustling he's my witness right
there he knows i was out every [__]
night when i was here in the beginning
there wasn't enough i didn't know what
it was to [__] stay home
yeah on the way home i'd make a stop and
you see it's so crazy it's been two
weeks run 20 bucks worth it 20 bucks in
gas to go and get paid 20 bucks yeah it
was [__] crazy i'm looking i'm going
this guy's nuts man i would do this
every night but at the end of the night
it would add up you know i i think i
don't know right or wrong it was like uh
i'm just having this vicarious kind of
rush right we just we're just playing
this guy i'm in this [__] movie and
and i'm watching this guy evolve you
know uh
i mean it it it was way different it was
not like anything else in the beginning
it was
there was something else you know it was
a different act you know
you you remember i mean you know you
started you was chat but it didn't
matter you just kept going
you just
you just kept going and every time hey
this works this doesn't work you know it
was like the comedy fueled the coke
but the coke kind of fueled the comedy
like i went out to do comedy because i
knew at the end of the night i was gonna
do coke let's be honest i'm not gonna
lie to nobody but for me to reward
myself with the coke
i would have to do two or three spots
that was my way of reward that was the
world i was living in late you know but
i was still growing as a comic
it's crazy how weird our brains are
that you could convince yourself that
was what i was doing to myself that's
the [__] that we got on this trip
so if i had don't remember all it took
was a 20 for me to get electrocuted
if if it was good
i would get high with the 20 hour jerk
off and go to bed
if it was shitty it would make me go for
another 20. somebody else i said
you know what i'm saying i don't know
nothing about checking off this is where
the addiction was
and
i was never a witness to that no nobody
said i whacked off
did things happen in your garage i
remember you you called me with some
strange [__] garage underneath well was
it uh
you know next to the lesbian uh place he
lived there for years with the 20 cats
uh
right there in hollywood uh oh yeah yeah
no i had no drama there
no there was i was there for nine
[__] years no no no no no
i was getting evil there
yeah i was getting higher there but i
wasn't uh
what do you call that [__] [__] it there
was no drummer yeah she never took it
you never didn't i don't know okay it
could be an out-of-body experience say
it say take a uh uh
you had to take
crap and now you just
you just did it right there you know
beside the car
you know i know one time in the backyard
[Music]
oh my god one minute i had to take a
crap i stopped the calling i got in
front of it in my garage i [__]
i wiped my butt i threw it over the poop
and i drove over it not with the tire
right over you couldn't even see it i
thought that was hysterical
in his driveway or something
in my driveway yeah okay so you just he
just you just told mike about it yeah
okay
yeah for that that's oh god
that's crazy
that was a crazy time
lee
you wouldn't have been talking to me at
this point you don't think so no
no
you have to hold on to your 2000 to 2006
i went [__] somewhere and it was
getting worse and worse and worse do you
think you would be talking to me though
like do you think you'd be looking for
that kind of help or no
no you'd let me go i'd be like your
other clients
i wouldn't call you back with a credit
card i wouldn't call you back with the
money
i would be an hour late there was always
a story
you know oh i'll give you that money
next week lee give me a hundred till
next tuesday
so it was just one of those [__]
things guys you know
but i'm happy to see you still healthy
i'm happy to see your kids healthy i'm
happy to see that
everything's still working
i'm happy to
let these people know we proved them
wrong what whether you're gonna say
you don't agree with none of this [__]
or whatever that's fine
guys like you and me
was you know
we put a lot to do a lot to do
things for things to be done
and uh
it's been uh
it's been a wild ride
joey dance what do you do now for work
i um
myself real estate
it's like cars without wheels
and do you like it i'm having a ball how
long have you been doing it for about
three years
you don't give up either
no you could have been up there and got
a retirement from your little vietnam
check right yeah and he said [__] it you
still work how old do you god bless you
70. 70 years old yeah
look at you
you're buying me you [__]
stop tapping on the goddamn table mike
that [__] comes up on the microphone
don't you hear it you [__] no
lee he was the worst driver than you
were
because he'd tell me fat tony stories
and look at me and drive on sunset
i almost died 82 [__] times
jesus lee it was a [__] nightmare
yeah i told him i told him one story
about fat frankie and forever because
i'm jesus not another frankie story it
was a frankie story constantly not
another driving [__] nutshell frankie
storyline would drive me [__] bananas
you have no idea but i wouldn't make him
cut people off
he used to go with what do you make when
you make you beat big people uncle mike
what do you make you go vote for me or
like be people or
zoom around people i have no memory in
it
you know we used to wait for the mailman
to come to the thing before we can make
a move yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we had the filipino mailman we would
wait for him at attention i would make
him pick me up every day at 10 to 12
months everyone that was a painful
period
no i'm serious oh god
at that point in my life i should have
been struck by light
i mean they're right if there really was
a god that would have happened that's
how evil i was here's how wetley
he'd get a call from me at 10th time i'm
coming obviously it's the past long past
will you come get me i don't know
anything about it he come get me by 10
to 12.
he'd come get me and then from there we
shoot right the garden and we wait for
the filipino mailman
and whatever we decided would be upon
the filipino mailman mike what do you
got
i got 20. mike what do you got i got 27
okay
i got [__] 22.
that means we got options we got a
starting point here we got something to
work with you know what i'm saying
if the checks don't come today then we
got something to work you got anything
coming in today okay
so all our whole day would be based on
the filipino mailman you played the
lottery every day every day once we saw
that truck we knew something was coming
no i'm not gonna lie to you
i knew most days nothing was coming
but in my demented cocaine world
something was always coming and guess
what way
i got surprised once a week
with like what level of check it was a
divine intervention in those days
the level of check that i needed was 63
dollars because i could take that right
to whitley yeah they'd give me 58
dollars after taking money out and i'd
go on my way
to check it and see now it's coming back
to you
because that's how the day worked lee
so we'd pull over right under a tree on
gardiner
right in front of [__] that building
and as soon as the mailman would come
along he'd say i'd have checked for you
today
and i get out of that [__] car and
i'd wait till he put the check in the
box
he couldn't hand me the check because it
said you can't do that you have to put
it in the [__] box and he closed the
box
before he closed the box i already had
the key in that [__] and i'd go
stand don't close it yet and i would
just open the thing and the checks would
fall out i put the rest of the mail in
and i take the checks out let's go we
got to go
and mike let's go to check cash in place
and we go from gardiner to whitley on
hollywood boulevard in 3.2 minutes flat
on the way to the [__] check cashing
place i'd already have johnny yayo on
the [__] phone asking him where he
was at
and how he could put this move together
early because the quicker we could put
the move together
that's it you don't have to think about
the rest of the day the rest of the day
was [__] a piece of cake
once you have what it took to put the
date now if i woke up and i had 200 in
my pocket
i would call mike to get chinese lunch
those are good days that's a good day
because i know i got a 60 for a g bowl
of ruin if mike needs a 60 i got it
that's how it worked in those days we
believe in that
if there was a check we'd cut half of
hollywood off and go to the check cash
in place of whitley cash that check
and from there we'd make a move he'd
disappear he dropped me off
and he picked me back up at 8 15 and
we'd make the move and seal it
or we'd figure something man he's i have
no idea why i thought that would be fun
but that's what what uh that's what it
was
yes for some reason it was
right you know what i'm saying that was
a different [__] time man yeah for
some reason i don't remember being
anything
but uh oh but i'm sure i could have
spent my time better than that
you know but
you know
you tried you were you were making money
you were supporting the family
you were feeding [__] mounds you know
you were still having a good time with
me because it was in your [__] blood
you're a new york city guy what are you
going to do dog um
you can't be ashamed of what on your
past is at any point in time
i mean no no no i've never even gone
into [__] specifics here got to be
we're going to [__] specifically
yeah god forbid but no it's just that
there's a time where you feel you're in
control and there's times you kill
you're not in control that's all i'm
still not in control i'm 53 years old
who gives a [__]
the more you're less in control the
better you know what i'm saying when
i've had it when i've been in control is
when i haven't been in control right
you know what i'm saying does that sound
right
what i mean by being in control you're
not in anyone's bidding at any point you
know you got to do what you got to do
but you know nobody's you know nobody's
got a leash around you and
you know you're not punching a clock you
know
you're an entrepreneur
you know i always thought that i had
this money coming to me
after my mother died i thought that my
dad would call me up one day and i
thought he would give me like a half a
million dollars but i'd take [__] 5
000.
see what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying could you have gotten
a bank account but you just wanted to
check immediately
like you like you just do that all the
time
exactly
at that time in my world either because
what was the necessity for a checking
account
a like that was that was
not what i wanted that wasn't
so wait a second what you're telling me
is
i gotta take my check go to your [__]
bank deposit i gotta wait a day even if
the check is cut i gotta wait till three
o'clock to get my money or the next day
i got no money
i'm living [__] hand to mount
i'd rather pay the 219 and get my cash
right there
than have to [__] around when you're in
that world
i've never been in that world that's the
world that you decide to choose on
you know and i would have 19 different
paychecks coming in
that's crazy in those days i would have
the comedy store check the improv check
the laugh factory check
they could amount to a total of 95
to me that was 22 million [__]
dollars okay
then you had your checks from
selling cigars on the phone
and then you had your checks from maybe
doing a short film or maybe doing you
know something
for whatever the [__] it was do you
phone saying to you the more months i
lived here the more all those checks
increased you also had money coming in
every night from the cash
gigs
and those in those in no in those days
in my world
and
in those days in my world it was uh
every night that i went out lee was cash
not in colorado but here getting paying
cash i got up to a point in los angeles
where for years you heard comics going
there's no reason to live in l.a you
don't make no money let me tell you
something i don't have those notebooks
no more
but years later i looked at those
notebooks
and you have no idea what i was making
in those rooms
well that's the point it's not that you
you can't make money if you're only
doing the comedy store left when i got
right when i got here in 98
it took me about two years to get
settled
but from 2000 to 2004
i had gigs every week
from forty dollars to 250
those 250 dollars damn
damn it feels good to be a geister
250 was like driving to san diego on a
saturday night or something now are
there other comedians who make a living
just still doing that circuit
listen man yeah you could i guess yes
you can
are you
yes you can are you whose phone is this
can you turn this [__] off please
yes you can make a living
it just
okay all power off there it is yeah
there you go there you go you can make a
living leave but you can't drive a
maserati
at that level at that level
at that level in l.a is it yeah is it
at that level okay leave your buddy
there tommy easton his level in that la
right now
an apartment
uh not [__] beverly hills in the
valley
okay
a day job
and at night
his goal is 200 a week in gigs guess
what lee
it's out there i know people will do it
you know how you get out there you have
to go to other gigs in silver lake and
all those other gigs and then those
people will tell you about a tuesday
night where a guy pays 85 bucks for 20
minutes up here and [__] uh
off off the 170 up there whatever that
is up there la clarita la placenta up
there i don't know at least but that's
how
you get those rooms
they'll start asking you about rooms in
santa barbara
those rooms are 150 on a [__]
thursday night if you put together a 250
on saturday and 150 that's 400. god
forbid you go out on [__] wednesday
and tuesday and pick up a hundred and
100 you understand what i'm trying to
say to you there's a living but
the more you go out and talk to people
and meet people people approach and go
hey man what are you doing next saturday
the 23rd i got this gig at this fire
department that we do once a month it
pays 75 do you want to do it
and next thing you know you're like can
i do the gig by nine because i got
another gig
right next to the city next to it that
pays two hundred dollars
so everything always works itself out
why you're hustling
if you believe it yourself that's the
level i was at in l.a
i can't lie and at that point lee i
looked you straight in there and i tell
you i was struggling i was probably
making 1600 a month cash on the road uh
in la
i was probably picking up another 700 on
the road in those days as a feature act
all right and i was probably picking up
anywhere from a thousand to two thousand
in tv and film every month and i could
look you straight in the [__] eye
right now and tell you i was walking
around [__] broken those days i can
barely make rent for 350. absolutely and
help my wife like the [__] friend of
the year
and groceries yeah
walking around brooke bummy closed the
whole [__] deal
how much of it do you think went to
cocaine what do you [__] think 45 40.
wow
because my wife only saw the checks she
didn't see the cash
if i did bring home cash i split with
what i got with it it's tough when you
get paid in cash you know how much
you're making you're following me yeah
so nobody really knew what i was making
in those days
so it was [__] wild when i think back
of that hustle you know
yeah
and i was naked and i was gone i was
making it work
i'm trying
i sit here amazed
thinking how i was making it work
as a comedian in two weeks i'll be here
20 [__] years
for the last three months
i have been thinking about this once a
day
that i could [__] tell everybody here
i thought i would last three years in
the city
i thought i would last three years go
back to boulder murder my wife
go to jail for the rest of my life
and that was how this [__] story was
gonna end this is the tragic story
of another [__] sack of [__] that got
taken by drugs
if i would have made it five years in
this town i thought i'd be lucky
when i first got off that [__] uh rv
in the back of my head i was like listen
if i make it here three years and get a
party as an extra i'll be [__]
thankful to god
at least i could tell people i was in
l.a
that's how i looked at it
oh wow
it's a weird town la there's a as soon
as you get here if it just feels
competitive it looks
i don't know dude at least it does for
me so
it's weird 20 20 years is amazing it's i
just hit six
and it's uh
i'm already i'm already like
looking like in the future to i don't
know how long i could stay here it's a
uh
it's a different it's a different kind
of lifestyle
lee your life wasn't planned for you i
do you [__] think i thought i'd be
here for 20 years no have you lost your
goddamn mind yeah i thought i would last
three years
tops
once i got into the store i was like
i hear they only give you spots for a
year at the store so i got like a year
to really put the pieces together
i was sure i wanted to go to new york
i i hated it out here when i interned
out here
jesus
lee you know what i didn't have a choice
to hate it or not to hate it when i came
here do you know
i got to be honest let me give you some
shout outs keep me posted i want to
thank bob lalingus and his family
for sending liam myself and the baby and
elmo and a beautiful
baseball and uh
and they uh
i'm back book a gorgeous book jimmy page
the three lives of jimmy page
pablo lingus and his family a [__]
church family thank you very much
matt holmeir family don wrangler
emmanuel colon
mary jane scott ookie spooky ali baz
over there in [__] australia having
heard from
grimace
mike model b
and my man santa romano
i want to give you a little love there i
don't know what's cracking up in your
life and [__] what you're doing
but that's uh
the real deal wasn't whether i had an
option to stay here or [__] natalie
this was it for the next couple years
until
something [__] happened i didn't know
nothing was gonna [__] happen you
didn't consider going back to denver to
do it or new york listen the only thing
that was going to happen in denver if i
went back to that movie
tempest was going to escalate
and something was going to happen
between me
that poor woman is a husband
that's all that i would have given in
six months
mike can't [__] think right now oh
man i can't answer questions right now
yeah i
could remember for five minutes the
anger i had in my heart in those days
that's why it's it's even to never mind
that i'm still doing comedy
just to think of getting that anger out
of my heart that i had
because there's no way you could
progress in your life
with any type of anger like that in your
[__] life and i did it
three or four times i thought i was so
angry at somebody i was gonna [__]
kill him
but you know what did you get out of it
how did i get out of it
and you can have because i remember
there's the time you wanted
you know what heals all wounds yeah yeah
yes you were talking about i mean i'm
[__] going oh no no it was terrible
it obsessed me yeah just the thought
that she had done i was worried about
you so
till this day there's nights that i sit
there and my body goes into like a
[__]
you know and i think to myself what the
[__] am i doing here i should be over
there
trying to kill them but you know what
what's wrong with me
what the [__] is wrong
what's wrong with me [__]
yeah i'm good what's wrong with me no no
no it's a different uh
it was a really looking at this story
and i'm going
wow no i would have been a guy if i
would have gone back to bowl to play
daddy
i would have still been doing time right
now this would have not ended well at
all
and new york
you know what i had been in new york
new york
i love new york it's where i grew up but
new york spelled one thing for me and
it's called easy access
what does that mean that i can have a
conversation with you at four in the
morning at five in the morning we could
be picking up a kilo and 181st in
amsterdam and on the way out the door
i'm gonna go to his name and buy a
machine gun
that's what that meant i didn't need
that in my life
that sounds very appealing yes you know
so
my question jesus so how
how did you have such a frank
conversation with yourself did you have
like do acid and think about it no at
that time there was no [__] acid
there was only there was only one drug
in my life in those days late
from 98 to 2007
there was basically two three drugs i
did
cocaine
maybe a sleeping pill somebody had or a
vicodin
and then for that one summer i did those
couple of packages of heroin
that's it there was no [__] confusion
about nothing else like so how so
i'm surprised i'm honestly surprised you
wouldn't go to the easy access of new
york that's my point
i don't i don't understand if you
understand what i mean by you know i i
do understand there has to be a blockage
in your life okay there has to be
you know even hey they make you wait to
go they make you call somebody does that
work nine out of ten times who the [__]
knows i've never been there where
you know what i want to get my dick
sucked and do some cocaine hold on
let me call my sponsor mel first
at two in the morning listen mel i gotta
talk to you about something enough is
enough i can't get a job my mother hates
me listen i gotta check from the va for
90. roy with the one arm over at [__]
the bar he's got grams for 80 and
they're kicking
my wife's got some old whiskey i'm going
deep you understand me no don't do it
read page 48 of psalm 4.
you know
the big book listen when i see you i'm
going to hit you with the big book
80 [__] times in the head i've never
had nobody call me and say joey listen
i'm thinking to shoot myself stop me i
don't have those type of friends
nobody's ever called me and said listen
i got a kilo i can't stop snorting you
gotta help me
nobody's ever called me with those
[__] calls that's all in the movies
and [__]
call your sponsor go [__] yourself
i got a blonde at the bar
she says if i can get a [__] eight
ball she'll suck my dick to the to the
skin color looks like michael jackson's
dick
she'll take the paint right off it
and and i gotta call my sponsor and ask
him you call your sponsor four in the
morning listen i haven't been cleaning
sober for nine years
but let me tell you the situation mel
there's a girl at the bar
says with an eight ball she'll do things
to my nut sack tongues in my ass what do
you think should we go for it one time
i'll be at a meeting tomorrow tip top
magoo
the guy will say go ahead go for it it's
been a long time you've been cleaning
soap but things happened who the [__]
knows you would if you had an aaa
sponsor you would torment them and they
would have quick aaa let me tell you
something i had when i was in the
halfway house i found an aaa sponsor for
a while that i found that
an aaa sponsor
and he talked me into
i was trying to go to n a
and he talked me into a a
and we would meet once a week in boulder
and talk about what was going on i had
to meet with my sponsor it was part of
the boulder halfway house
that was part of you had he had to sign
the pace of paper why would you go if
you weren't an alcoholic
because the principles were the same
okay addiction is addiction you know
that's how he explained it to me
he was a realist he was like uh
he was
you know what i talked to him for about
a year even though i was doing blow he
was a real dynamite white dude dynamite
dynamite white people from the heart of
this country like
omaha nebraska or something this dude
was tight he wasn't judgmental i learned
a lot a lot of [__] little things
from having like a little [__]
sponsor
and guess what happens
i disconnect with him i bump into him 18
months later he goes you look great you
look great too
i said listen i gotta be honest here
i've been smoking dope this morning was
that don't worry about it he goes i've
been smoking dope like a [__]
myself [__] all nonsense that [__] don't
work i think he went off about something
that was the end of that that's a
stereotype i'm sorry yeah you know no
but i believe no no i believe i believe
it i believe it i just don't think i
could call it
[__] like that happen you know the time
i listen for three or four years it
wasn't that i was doing i wanted to do
coke it was the situations i was getting
myself into
yeah yeah you know what do you mean a
suicide mission you know you're at the
comedy store bro and there's a hot chick
and she's visiting from [__] new
jersey and she's talking about she wants
to party
and you know she's a freak
or whatever the [__] is going on i don't
know lee just
different situations you
people come to the store and they're
literally that kind of thing somebody
comes to look there by blow
and you get on the gram and often they
give you half of it
you know
it happens to everyone yeah sure it does
happen to me all the time doesn't it
yeah
jesus
when you're hooked on drugs
whatever drug it is
it's like a metal it's just like
carrying a gun i've said it a thousand
times when you put a gun on your waist
it's like a medal for trouble when you
do drugs you know yeah i gotta tell you
something yeah yeah that's right in 30
years of doing drugs
let's pretend i did cocaine for 25 years
you know in those 25 years how many
times
i got approached by people
asking me if i want to do
heroin
maybe three times the only times people
came up to me
and asked me if i want to do meth maybe
three times
you know how many times people came up
to me and asked me if i wanted to do
blow oh about a million point [__]
eight times
why because you're a magnet for that
[__]
in hollywood i knew i knew two people
who did heroin
i know these two lesbians you can ask
josh wolfe me and joshua for friendzone
these two ladies were solid women
both of them good looking tattooed up
they would lock themselves in that
apartment eat monkey and [__] shoot
heroin and they wouldn't take showers
or they would take showers without soap
because they wouldn't unclog their skin
pores
we've discussed this [__] before did did
you guys know each other when you were
living in your car in italy who
you too me and mike yes sir i don't know
if mike was here when i was living in my
car where we where where where would he
be living in l.a when i was living in my
car by ralphie's house when i had that
no i think i got it right after that
yeah he got here shortly after that
no you had a place i think yeah that's
that same place you had
the name of the street
shermer
with the lesbian
the center next to it yeah yeah with
terry yeah with my wife who was my wife
now yeah yes
that's when i was there
but i wouldn't use that as my address i
would use
gavin and ralphie's apartment has
managers
i would use
gardner
as my
address that's why i chased the mailman
on [__] gardener all the time
you remember chasing that [__]
mailman
you saw a lot of things man even though
you ain't the stars of death and you
can't remember
you saw a lot of [__] good stuff i
deny everything
remember we went to see that spanish
dude
at the house of blues that was playing
the conga drums
yes actually yeah
and he asked me if i get him a package
talking about see like i hadn't seen him
in [__] 20 years
and the first thing he said to me can
you get a [__] package
oh god
would it upset
you did it upset me
no no it didn't upset me at all no you
didn't get one i like it no i didn't get
it from i went home
[__] him i told him i'd be back
i just wanted to say hello to him to see
what it was like i knew him as a child
you know right and then he asked you for
coke it must have been disappointing
no it wasn't disappointing it was uh
it was what it was
those were the times those were the
people i knew at that time at that age
it's a shame what's the matter mike uh
who was that potato
or satiko poteko was dead at that point
but uh
mike was a manager of the car store or
something
and one of the salesmen was a conga
player
so mike talked to the kid about the
congas
and the kid told mike to go see that guy
that night that's how i found out about
him i don't even think i was going to
the store then
at that time i wasn't going to the store
i had already stopped going to the store
we just parked and went to the house of
blues and left the house of blues and i
went home i think the show started at
eight we stay we stayed for maybe three
songs
uh
yeah something like that yeah i can't uh
i can't be cooped up for much longer
than that
but there was like uh
yeah there was some that there were some
really beautiful cuban women
i remember that's tremendous and then
you don't remember nothing first you're
[__] right first you're being that
dude and godfather too you don't know
nothing and now you remember cuban women
first for two hours you don't know
nothing that's just dancing yeah
it was culture it was culture it was
cuban culture
it was raw
it was the real thing
i'm happy you're still alive and kicking
jesus i'm happy you're still doing your
thing i don't know a long evolution for
this you had you used to have a
trampoline in your backyard in boulder
it's the truth
it's amazing nobody dies
it's absolutely these [__]
these people think
you know
it's taken me a while to write
the first three chapters of these intros
but i gotta tell you something i sit
there
and i exercise my mind and i outline
them
like today i wrote like three paragraphs
in like two minutes because i outlined
it
i knew exactly what i had to write it's
a lot easier
i'm not writing a lot
but i'm writing and in the words of
[__] shakespeare
little commitments become big
commitments you know i'm saying
i don't know shakespeare spoke like that
me neither i'm just [__] saying if he
didn't
a man of shakespeare's [__] stature
would speak that way you're following me
[__] what do you got planned this
weekend i'm going to tempe that sounds
[__] what the [__] are you doing this
weekend
uh what plans are you involved in this
weekend is there a a dog hugging
convention
hermosa beach
is there a coupon
class for crepes
surprised me you haven't blown my doors
off in 2017.
you don't need to tell me you've been
staying in
eating [__] chicken and vegetables
every night for the last four weeks is
that what you've been trying to tell me
i haven't been staying in at all i
haven't had
i've been like the first
two weeks of the year without having a
day off so i don't i don't have any
plans for this weekend yet
i kind of
have adopted your style of
just doing that day so i i honestly have
no idea yeah no pug hugging festivals no
pug hugging festivals come on itchy with
a rash and [__] this is the first trip
you wanna you didn't come back with a
rash or a
red eye or skunk [__] i don't know
what it is in my goddamn family tree
that makes my skin so terrible
i'm excited about going to temp you
haven't been in about 18 months
you know i've been going to tempe since
i first [__] got here i'd love you in
terms of you could just go to tempe for
so long before you go you know what he's
going to come again i said you know i
don't want to let that be for a long
[__] time i used to go down there for
a long time and i stopped going down
there and then [__] danny murph
[__] died and then nobody went
and they tried to ship me off to phoenix
and they reopened tempe it's another
tempe i was there when the when [__] i
was telling lee about the dude greasy
tony that he had a restaurant there
across the street from the improv
next to a gas station and a bar i've
been going there since [__] 98 down
there first time i went to tempe arizona
was an 84
to hook up with a friend of mine and we
ended up smoking mushrooms
it was [__] tremendously and with
some indians
it was like something out of a [__]
movie lee i left there like going
this life is gonna be a wild [__]
ride
i went back to tempe
14 years later it was a complete
different [__] city
it had grown that whole area had grown
leaps
and [__] bounds and the first time i
went down there i think that's one of
the weirdest parts about getting older
is just coming back like 10 years later
in the and having memories somewhere but
that was the first city where i first
noticed that
that i flew into to do comedy like
and
i don't know it was like i knew i had
been there before i'd been there twice
before the tempe i landed twice in
phoenix and then went on to tempe both
times
but i remember like the the whole thing
how much he had blown up you know
so yeah i've been going at it but the
greasy tony was down there he was a dude
from jersey
we had this little hot he was short he
was stumpy he was dirty he had a [__]
up haircut
greasy tony had all the [__] up
makings
of just a little little bonnet he just
looked like somebody and he was he was
somebody from middle new jersey you know
he had no class he was worse than i was
i mean he was just nuts but he had this
restaurant and he served great [__]
sandwiches i mean gabriel used to go
there martine moreno rogan myself
chris mcguire i mean ari duncan we would
go to
we would go to the tempe improv
and drive
just to go to uh greasy tony's first
before the stop keep tapping on the
[__] table we would go to greasy tony
we would drive down there
and go to greasy tony's
just to get like a [__] sandwich he
had pizzas but i was telling lee he made
his own mountain dew
one day one of our friends drank a
mountain dew and said i don't know what
happened last night but i didn't sleep
for like a day and a half
and he goes i [__] narrowed it down
to greasy tony and i asked him about his
mountain dew
and he told me that that's why he didn't
put it in the
gun because he would mix his own like it
was in a bucket yeah like
if you asked the family
or do you just dip the cup in there
if you knew greasy tony
he [__] he dipped his hand in there
picked it up put ice cubes in it let the
juice peel over and go all over his
disgusting fingers
and then he'd give it to you if you knew
greasy tony oh my god he had [__]
mountain dew in a tub that he made
himself because
that's what kept him awake he was
addicted to mountain dew
so he would take the juice from the
mountain dew gun
and just mix it like it's like i don't
know the exact measurements i'm just
saying he would take that thick syrup
and let's say you were supposed to mix
an ounce of syrup
with six ounces of water let's just say
it's gonna be a lot lesser he would mix
it with like three ounces of water
and it would be like a stew the ice
cubes it was like egg drop soup
like a good egg drop soup but you had to
put like ice cubes in it to tame it down
and that's when it thicker thins up a
little bit when you put ice cubes into
egg drop soup that's the way it was with
his mountain dew just it was cold in the
[__] he put ice a ton of ice in it you
didn't even know what the [__] you were
drinking it burned your throat
and called it it burned your throat it's
like if you know anything about
coca-cola
those little bottles they burn your
throat
because they have more oxygen in those
for years coca-cola used to make an
eight-ounce bottle or a 10-ounce bottle
and the reason why people drank them
people would say oh my god whenever you
drink the eight the ten ounce cokes they
would burn your throat it's a different
coca-cola no it's the same coke they
would just either take the oxygen out or
put more oxygen in i forget what's the
thing if somebody will know and they'll
tweet at me what the formula was a lot
of people don't know about that see so
you could do the same [__] with mountain
dew
he would make his own [__] mountain
dew mountain crank
you up for [__] days
i did a triple run one time and i had to
drive from idaho to boulder colorado
i'll never forget this
i got off stage at [__] 10 30.
and i know for a fact it was like 12
hours from
boise idaho to boulder it was the night
of the final four or something like that
and somebody was in the finals ucla the
twins
something
and i was trying to not stay and watch
the game i said let me watch it for 10
minutes
i ended up leaving at 10 40.
and i had to be in boulder by two
[__] o'clock
no sleep no nothing it was going to be a
12 hour [__] ride so if i'm leaving
at 10 30
i'm gonna get that 10 30 in the morning
i'm gonna have three hours of sleep a
shower and get myself together
it was to pick up my daughter on sundays
i got in that [__] car
and i started guzzling mountain dew and
my uh not mine at all
my goal is when you have your period no
nose no nose
dog i started eating those [__]
caffeine jesus christ that's so bad for
you
that was it that was i never mess with
no those are going to happen
that's the most dangerous thing you've
ever done
for 12 hours troy i would only stop for
gasoline
i got all the way to bold and i got a
message saying that she wasn't dropping
the kid off that day she was sick
i drove all [__] night i'll never
forget i pulled over in one of those
idaho towns
and i parked on the side of the road and
i tried to sleep
and i took like a six minute nap and i
woke up to the to me stepping on the gas
with the lights on so when i opened up i
thought i was going off a cliff oh no oh
my god oh my god how much your [__]
heart beats until you wake up high
i wasn't high i was high on those
[__] no dozers in mountain dews
what a [__] life man
what do you think mike when you look at
joey now
uh
oh
it uh
you know it the miracle continues you
know i mean look it's it's uh
you know
you know these uh
what did i eat uh the black death
instead of [__] yeah so
it's
it's it's this long journey right and
it's like
and it's you know it's got so much edge
you know towards the dark side and
there's all this other stuff but we just
had this love man i was like [__] it man
you know
uh
but uh
what a strange trip and what a really
strange trip strange [__]
1990s
2007 [__] team
but but but right now you know anybody
said you here's what i think
uh we're both doing the right thing
when it comes to like uh
living living no no we were living like
animals for a long time there's no way
you could live like that family even
move
ahead
serious family thing yeah
so
we stuck together
you know uh we had we're partners in
crime it was [__] tons of fun
would i do it again [__] yeah we never
ended up in prison
you know we always had you know the
other day you reminded me of the story
you had the spanish
and he would make me call him up and
talk to him in spanish
like would call me and come down here
and also come down and go talk to this
guy ask me what he said
and the guy would say i'll meet him on
the corner wilshere
so we had to take a right to [__]
he'd make the delivery and then
me and mike were behind compadre one
night
and i met my most famous [__] drug
dealer of all time
nobody impressed me more than this guy
we looked at each other and we both knew
we were the same souls of the same bird
he was a mexican dude we made eye
contact
and he came right out to me lee and he
was
this guy was a weird guy he was saying
come on
and he would hug he only spoke spanish
and he put a coke rock in your nose
and then he looked you straight in the
eye he goes how much do you want
and you would say give me 20 give me 40.
give me 50. give me a hundred he just
put a rock in your head
like he knew exactly from the size of
the rock so i met him behind our
compadre i got like a 40 from him he
gave me like a 60 since i was a new
customer you know zone he hooked me up
you know this is just how much it's
worth right right this what i'll get
it's a 40 bag a 60 bag it's a 40 bag he
gave me like
for 40 he should have gave me like eight
tenths of a gram
he gave me i gave him 40 and he gave me
a gram and a tent you know i'm saying
something like that it was random
clean coke the whole [__] deal
so at that time there was him there was
the armenian there was a couple drug
dealers at the [__] uh al
so every night was different competition
it was the dude who played the guitar
he's dead now god rest his soul
was he creepy
no he wasn't creepy at all he was
[__] tremendous and
so every night when you went in there
you knew you were going to get something
you just didn't know from who it was
always an adventure
if you caught the armenian it was a good
night and you could talk to him he'd
give you the good [__]
if you caught the the guitar player he'd
and if you caught the uh who else was i
talking about there was somebody else
[Music]
i don't know if i can say his name or
not no no no he didn't hang out there
the black dude yeah no no no he didn't
hang out there we got him always on the
sidelines okay he was always in the
sidelines he was the martell cartel
look at mike he remembers now it's
coming back to him and he said look i
don't know nothing about knowledge he
knows what i'm talking about
he sat out there outside the synagogue
many [__] nights with uncle joey
thinking about his life and [__]
what are we saying lee before
oh so i meet this dude
he puts the [__] coke rock in my hand
i go home i don't see the guy for a few
months right
but
a few months later i get off the 101.
i get off the 101 on sunset
but no i get off the sign up you know
when you're coming north
on uh 101 you hit santa monica melrose
right and in those days i would always
anticipate traffic because i had a spot
at the store
so i would exit on there and make a left
and head towards the beach and i would
stay on melrose for maybe until i hit
vine then i cut up type [__] you know
what i'm saying absolutely i cut up to
like one of those main streets fountain
and i'd go straight to the comedy store
i cut up on one of those streets
it's got to be
12 30 at night
now when you get to western and sunset
there's a mcdonald's another mcdonald's
there's like a
subway sandwich there used to be a
sprint store stair
there's a big lumber yard there right
there on sunset and across the street is
that store i told you
it's a lumber yard type place and
there's mexicans on the way out there
but in there they saw the best tacos in
l.a
all those all his clients are mexican so
they got to sell the mess beck's food do
you understand me so getting back to
that story
i'm on that street on sunset and [__]
western i'm minding my own business
it's 12 45.
i got some money in my pocket i'm not
lying to you i'm headed to hell compadre
i'm gonna go to the store and pick up a
package you know me
i got money in my pocket it's burning a
hole in my pocket
do you know i'm sitting there minding my
own business looking out the window to
see
when the light's going to turn green and
red
and who do i see running at me but that
[__] drug dealer
from behind our composure not like a
wild man going hey
hey
remember me
he was like hiding behind a car
saw me and remembering me
and he ran into the car breathing heavy
hey pull over pull over you don't get to
see it i go i got to talk to you and all
this i go what's up dog and i was they
put a coke rock in my nose and i
remembered who he was i'm like look who
the [__] it is
and he was scared he had good blow i
looked yeah yeah and i gave him like 60
bucks and he gave me like a [__] gram
and that grant and i got a half
and that was that i was a customer i go
what are you here
and he would tell me listen whenever you
want coke you don't even need to call me
just come down here
driving around for two or three minutes
i'll come running to your car
do you know that yeah i didn't like
[__] ten times lee
all you had to do was drive to sunset
make a ride on western
go down make a ride again by the time
you hit sunset the second time you hear
hey
it sounds like the man on fire
instructions like to find he was always
like in a tree always under a car
this was [__] great you can't believe
you cannot write this [__] you
understand me this is what keeps me up
at night and i go i don't understand
you don't
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
i'm lucky i'm here no no no
you just think about how many things
could have gone wrong
that could have been a cop three blocks
away at a light and sees a guy dropping
something off in my car right now we
wouldn't be having this conversation i'd
be just getting out of jail i'd be
getting out of a [__] halfway house
if you understand me how many things
could have gone wrong in those days
that's why i'm so [__] lucky i didn't
do nothing no you didn't [__] do
nothing jesus christ almighty
if it ain't one thing it's another yeah
but what are you gonna do i'm going to
[__] tempi
least i ask him to sit at home he's
going to [__] develop his business
he's taking over the world trump's been
again become president but lee siyat is
going to [__] take over trump's
position in the podcast world trust me
wrong telling you this [__] people
that's family thank you very much i'm
trying are you going to the inauguration
march or any of the events like
for trump no i am i'm busy that weekend
no
i'll watch i'll watch some of it
probably are you going to any of the
demonstration marches or anything like
that no i don't
go to downtown l.a on saturday
i would rather i would rather
jump off a bridge and go to any
demonstration rally yeah
that sounds terrible
no it's insane i mean it's it's it's a
very interesting time
because i don't know what to think
there's a lot of people in my life who
are very scared
yeah really huh yeah there's a lot of
people in my life jesus christ there's a
lot of people in my life are very scared
right now scared like about like like
trump uh yeah and it's not the people
you think because i'm
yeah
really yes it's my it's like it's uh i
feel like
let me ask you a question you're an
intelligent kid you watched a lot of
[__] tv and whatever
what are the fears
you know what i uh what are the [__]
fears of the americans i don't even want
to say them because
because you were afraid no no no because
it's
even to me it was ridiculou like it
seemed a little bit ridiculous
because just
yeah
like there are people out there
it's okay
who are worried that he will like not
allow other people not not allow an
election like he'll he'll and like he'll
start not allowing people into the
country like he'll do
so i and animal and i don't want to
speak out of turn so
and i don't i don't necessarily think
i'm hoping
that just one person doesn't have that
much power
so that's what i'm kind of banking on uh
but it it a lot of people are scared
that he's gonna take
the all
medical
insurance away from millions of people
he's gonna
a lot of people are worried about the
marijuana industry
they're just gonna do have a lot more uh
conservative
values on a lot of the
parts of our life
all right so i mean i but i i don't know
i guess it's probably what the people in
the south would
didn't like when this was happening
when obama happened i'm sure it's the
same feeling
to be honest with you is it it's going
to be very interesting to see what
happens yeah i think friday and saturday
and sunday across the country there's
going to be rallies i'm hoping he's good
i'm a lot of women i'm rooting for him
oh that's sick of bespoke this is spooky
time
yeah get ready kids
fast and receipt belts it's going to be
a rough ride you know it depends what
happens oh now you got a [__] crystal
ball [__] sucker before you don't know
nothing you want to plead the fifth okay
yeah you want to tell these [__]
they're in for a spooky time not spooky
no no no hey listen remember the 60s
people used to do this right and it was
like hey it was fun when i was like 18.
yeah [__] let's go demonstrate
but now this is like serious and people
do need to do it it's great but it's
real it's real if you're gonna go do
that and the thing i was thinking about
today to be honest with you is
there are people who like the same
people who are scared about trump
don't necessarily like bernie they were
very much hillary clinton
so but it seems like to me
that if if bernie is around and up for
it that he would probably have a
landslide
like it would be it would be
probably a huge
battle between him and trump i'm not
going to say a landslide victory but
i'll say a huge battle because he he
people feel like he got robbed
of a chance i was robbed so i think if
in four years he's still up for it
either him or biden would
would have a it would be a more it would
be a better battle than the last one
anyways yeah
he's he's he's there and yeah it don't
matter listen
to the supermarket we're there by
ourselves that's the thing nobody
there's no president there there's no
way america's uh your [__] check
america is a very strong thing
you know people have their fears
believe in yourself
yeah [__] everything else that's why
really but days are back [__] you
understand me
that's the best thing about this whole
situation that bidets are back they've
made a strong comeback
if it wasn't for hellotushy.com
you'd still be wiping your ass getting
blisters and
scratching your hemorrhoids with that
cheap [__] dollar store paper but
thank god for hellotushi.com who put a
new revolutionary what's it called
really help me here what's it's called
when you can snap it on
it's portable it's portable
but then but day hot water and cold
water yeah it's amazing that i have just
a cold water one but it takes literally
15 minutes to install and you don't have
to have any sort of special tools or
anything crazy it's really easy
it's like i have i think i had a wrench
and i and i'm and i probably could have
dealt with my wife installed it that's
why i don't talk about this [__] i just
listen i just take a dump and i sit on
it and i put the water and i gotta tell
you it's a different dimension oh yeah i
get a lot of you people i did a 90-day
test on my muffler and things have
changed down there you understand me
listen valentine's day is around the
corner everybody wants a clean [__]
here's your chance to give somebody a
valentine's day card and tell them at
the same time the [__] smells like a
goat without them knowing it you know
what i'm saying you could tell you i
love you and your [__] smells like
dead [__]
apes
by the same time
go to hellotushy.com right now there's a
60-day guarantee on these things but let
me tell you something if i sat on it for
90 days
you your little bony ass you'll do great
with it you follow me
go to hellocushy.com right now and press
in church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off you
understand me this is the way listen you
can't walk around with that swamp ass
all day no you can't that's how you get
bacteria it's great it goes to the back
of your scrotum if you're a woman
when your fart it backfires and it goes
into your monkey you can't have that so
that's why you gotta have a portable
bidet keeps away the hemorrhoids it
takes away the swamp ass you'll be
tiptoot
ready to go you understand me
like catwoman you can just go in your
little secret bathroom this isn't funny
no it's not funny so stop [__]
laughing here
these people are [__] tremendous
people with tremendous product and i
want america and the world to understand
that hello tushy does [__] work and
they're tremendous thank you i wouldn't
[__] be here talking about them if
they would go to hellotushy.com right
now and press in church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your order also it's a
new year you're still eating those
[__] up vitamins you're still lying to
yourself go to honor.com right now and
press in judge boom and get 10 off your
order delivered right to your
[__] door from alpha brain to
shroom tech to shroom tech sport to to
what else [__] help me here
uh uh listen to this
listen go to honor.com and take a great
look at all the true
they even have
like a alpha brain travel thing that you
take i forget what they called i'm sorry
we ain't too many stars tonight pardon
me and my [__] mum and bumbling
little goomba
over there
killing me that strong bone go to
hunter.com right now start your new year
resolution stick it out i can't help you
with the steel bars or the kettlebells
but i'll give you 10 percent off on the
supplements go to on the right canal and
press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent of your
first order see you [__] next
week stay black i love you and don't
forget about me
[Music]
mother didn't need to be so high